We have more things in common than
differences. Culture is one of them.
I thought that a trip like this could
benefit both countries. There is no place
in the world that you travel and you
don't find musicians imitating American
music, Brazilian music, and Cuban music. For me it's mandatory to come to the
island and go into the countryside, into
the clubs, go in to the theatre, it's
something special that I wanted to share
with my students at Harvard. I wanted
them to breathe the culture of that.
Yes we learn from all the books that we
read, we learned from all the lectures
that we take, but it's only with
experience that we can actually grow.
So many times during that performance I was
just like, how did I get here? It's unlike
anything I've ever seen. I don't think I
expected this at all, you know, Yosvany
he'll play the chekere every once in a
while so I guess you get a little bit of
a hint what something like this is
actually like but, nothing really
compares to this right there.
This is the Ethiel Faílde
Today we got the amazing opportunity to
go to a concert hall and learn from Miguel
Faílde's danzon group and we
also got invited up on stage to play
with the group.
By the very nature of Professor Terry
being from Cuba it's been a remarkable
experience to tour this enigma of a
country with someone so invested and
familiar with the country.
The first 24 hours
I would say was a little bit of a
culture shock for me simply because it
is my first trip internationally. It's
really hard not having been out of the
United States to really understand how
different other cultures are. We have
been fortunate to have some of the best
artists collaborating with us because
when you normally go to a concert, they
never stop the show to say this is what's
happening, this is the deity that this
person is dancing for. When we went to
Guines and we have the opportunity to
see as some of the members of the
National Folkloric Troupe, at the end of
the show you saw the students trying to
learn the clave, trying to learn some
of the rhythmic pattern, trying to
learn some chants, trying to dance so
that they could understand the beats, the
rhythm, how to feel them, and how to feel
it with their body which is important. In
all of the stops that we have made there
has been this engagement with learning,
this engagement with taking something
home, taking something with you forever.
Music has a unique power and it's the
power of healing and the power of
transformation, and I know that this is
really important for all the students, I
know I can see the students transformed.
This trip has probably taught me more
than I've learned in a lot of classrooms
over the past couple of years. There's
something about being in a different
country in a different cultural setting,
having the kind of access and the
different connections that Yosvany
has brought us has just really opened my
eyes to basically a whole new world, and
I think "life changing" might be a bit
cliché, but I don't think there's any way
that I'll go forward with the rest of my
Harvard career or even probably with the
rest of my life having experienced what
I have over the past week.